you've got to activate the thinker in
you don't allow your emotions to control
you if you don't discipline and contain
your emotions they will use you your
mind goes on automatic just like a God
weeds don't have to have any
encouragement to grow you don't have to
water them they don't have to get
sunshine they don't have to have fertile
ground they will grow through the cracks
of a sidewalk but if you want to grow
orchids or roses or any kind of exotic
flowers there are special processes and
procedures you must go through you don't
have to force yourself or motivate
yourself to think negatively to be
depressed to hate somebody to want
revenge you want to get back at somebody
to beat yourself up over the head to
feel loaded with guilt you don't have to
make any effort to do that you've got to
be willing to harness your will your
mind is on automatic it will do that by
itself but if you want to begin to move
into your own personal greatness if you
want to begin to really enjoy a happy
successful healthy life you've got to be
willing to go against the tide you've
got to be willing to harness your will
and say in spite of this I'm in control
here I'm not gonna let this get me down
I'm not gonna let this destroy me I'm
coming back and I'll be stronger and
better because of it you have got to
make a declaration that this is what you
stand for you're standing up for your
dreams you're standing up for peace of
mind you're standing up for health you
want it and you're gonna go all out to
have it it's not going to be easy when
you want to change it's not easy if it
were in fact easy everybody to do it but
if you're serious you'll go all out I
don't care how good you are until how
care how talented you are I don't care
how much you work on yourself there
sometimes when things aren't going to go
right they just I'm not going to go
right why I don't know why that's called
life
and you have to deal with it sometimes
your life will be in a slump just like
sports some of the best shooters can't
hit baskets they get in a slump do they
sit on the sidelines no they continue to
execute it if you were facing a
challenge
don't stop stay busy work your plan
continue to move stay busy stay busy
stay busy
you just watch - amazing clips from Les
Brown take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]